Trump goes against Hillary was it
because he was the best possible
candidate was it because Hillary was
just the worst possible candidate on the
left
she was a garbage candidate I mean not
just a bad candidate blaming garbage
dumpster fire began to think if Biden
runs in 2020 I think it was I'm not sure
the rock hasn't cleaned everybody if he
runs so listen if you do not know this
face you don't turn on the television
you don't watch Instagram you don't
watch YouTube you pretty much don't
watch anything linked to politics
because the man sitting next to me has
got a very interesting story I'm gonna
tell you why we're sitting with Ben
Shapiro today I was with Dennis Prager a
few months ago and I was with the Jerry
Springer and the conversation went into
politics everybody all these people
invited me to pack you got to get Ben
Shapiro you got to get Ben Shapiro you
got to get Ben Shapiro so we did for
some of you that do not know who this
man is let me give you a little bit of a
background on a bench Shapiro one he
graduated high school at 16 years old
okay apparently was a five to one 20
June yrs what I just found out about him
he became the youngest syndicated
columnist in America at 17 years old
okay he graduated from UCLA at 20 years
old
I think bachelor's in political science
and then you go to Harvard Law and you
graduate there at the top of your class
then you start a consulting and a law
from consulting company yourself and you
go to bribe art and our daily wire and
now you are to know he's the number one
conservative podcast around the world do
not spend [ __ ] for your buddy don't you
have you on valium in here with us so
Ben let's get right into it I have one
simple question for before we even get
into all the other political questions
your brain moves a million miles a
second you're just gonna it's gonna saw
like and when I watch your eyes so many
thoughts come out so quickly but it's so
perfect like perfect melody when it
comes out have you always been like this
since you were a kid yeah I always was
able to articulate my thoughts
relatively clearly and I think it's
gotten better as I've gotten older I
mean I hope I don't speak the same way I
did when I was 2 but so it's been a
speech contest when I was in third grade
so it's not it's not a speech contest so
were you the kid that you always debater
your mom and dad mom I don't know if I
agree with this that I know my
were you that nothing that I got along
with my parents really well okay I still
get along with my parents really well
they'll about a mile away so so how did
you form your political beliefs was it
parents was it schooling was it the
teacher was it a mentor how did this
come about for you it's mostly parents
O'Connor that's because my politics I
think are more an outgrowth of values
than they are of my desires to talk
about tax rates I just I think that the
stuff that really matters is the is the
value based living that we all do and so
when I was young there are a couple of
rules in the house one of them was that
if you made him as he cleaned it up and
the other was that if you were not
working hard and we're doing your job
and that those two things are gonna make
you a conservative I mean if you believe
that that responsibility lies with you
and that effort is the key then I think
that you're going to end up probably in
a more conservative frame mud just
because it's a very meritocratic basis
for living and also you know even though
as a smart kid I know there's a lot of
people out there of course Martin I am
for sure
I mean I went to a junior high in North
Hollywood called Walter Reed that had a
highly gifted program they give you an
IQ test to get in and I got it right and
get in about like a thousand points
there were kids there who had
significantly higher IQs than I did but
I just knew that I was gonna have to
work harder denied it and now you you
know Google them and a lot of them are
in jail a lot of it is effort based and
not IQ based and I think that's true for
most most folks have you always been
somewhat competitive have you always
been a pretty competitive kid I mean
obviously you have two kids your family
now but I'm someone you were coming up
will you competitor only competitive one
challenged I think this is interesting
I'm not looking for a competition I'm
not looking to play games with people
but if somebody starts to get
competitive then then I get committed
somebody challenges you you don't you
don't add all back down you go back yeah
whether it's the Pierce what was a
Pierce Morgan interview when at that
time everybody was talking about gun
laws gun this gun that and you address
them whether it's a another one that you
were sitting next to somebody and she
put her hand on you and she tried to
stop me yeah that was pretty interesting
I was watching that but it's very easy
to watch you it's amazing it's very
interesting watching you and you just
kind of see you know you sit there you
hear them then you come out with an
argument and all of a sudden they're
backed up they don't know what to say
then you go back again and then the
conversations go into a whole different
direction then they're calling names you
have a
interesting way of debating different
topics that you go through with people
so here's a question for you that I
asked Prager as well as Jerry Springer
so you said your parents you grew up
knowing you have to pick up after you
you made a mess or cleanup and then you
have to work hard yet to learn about
hard work all that stuff and your family
what if your parents were Bill and
Hillary Clinton who would Ben Shapiro be
today hard to say because I'm not sure
they were ever in the same house at the
same time but aside from that Chelsea
seems like a nice young person I mean
IIIi think that you know those those
values should be something relatively
Universal my big problem with Bill and
Hillary Clinton just as human beings is
their focus on victimhood and politics
for their own political gain if there's
a real problem my guess is that when
they raise their own children when there
is Chelsea they're probably teaching a
lot of those same values because I think
all successful people of any stripe have
to abide by those values I don't think
that those are political values again I
think that if you're successful in life
you have to abide by those two simple
rules you got to clean up your own mess
and you got to work hard and so if you
are successful then it's a pretty good
shot that somebody along the way taught
you those guys because they're very few
people who leave message for others or
are lazy who do really well in a free
country so here's what I'm asking a
question from you man
so both Jerry and Dennis gave two
different answers the question is a big
part of when I study how we form our
opinions political opinions right you'll
see a trend with if a kid grew up in a
family loving family the kid you know
kid typically follows parents of
philosophies belief system and then if
you know mom and dad were really loving
or something was even deeper then it
becomes a crusade some of them become
true believers you've read some of the
books on true believers you're obviously
true believer Jerry's a true believer
craigers a true believer you've got a
lot of these guys that are true
believers right but what if truly what
if your parents were not billon he wrote
Hillary let me pick another president
that was democratic what if your parents
were Jimmy Carter what if your father
was Jimmy Carter very good to you
everything would you still be as big of
a libertarian as you are today as big of
a conservative as you are today I mean I
hope so
but I don't really know I mean I I
assume that you know the experiences the
people have gone through shaped their
politics but I hope that ID wise up to
Jimmy Carter's interventionist ways I
think that liked it was a brilliant guy
by the way a very smart
a car is very IQ very high cute guy but
but his values are completely wrong when
it comes to politics because well he is
I think personally an honest fellow I
think that his belief in interventionism
in the free market Springs from his own
belief in his own brilliance I think
that again one of the things that going
back to that second rule about effort
the 1/1 the corollary is that rule is
that no matter how naturally smart you
are that's not enough you actually have
to go out and and work for yourself what
that means politically is that no matter
how smart you are you're not smarter
than the crowd so if you are the
smartest guy in the room you're so much
smarter than all the other people who
argue in the crowd put together and I
think that one of the problems you see
with both Barack Obama and Jimmy Carter
both of whom are very smart guys is this
belief that I'm the smartest guy in the
room therefore I know what how to do
everybody else's job and that means that
I get to centralize all power and myself
and I can order society better than
everybody else is ordering society go
yeah I haven't I know enough about
myself and I know enough about other
folks to know that even if I am smarter
on a pure IQ level than somebody there's
a good shot they know a lot more about
their particular business than I know
about their particular business so again
the reason why I asked this question I'm
asking it from everybody here's why I'm
asking this question because I think the
biggest challenge for Charlie Kirkus
while I was with Charlie Croker I think
he was in Dallas we were sitting down
talked and he says you know I'm running
this you know the organization turning a
phenomenal job
I mean Charlie's gonna be somebody in
politics yeah Charlie I don't know if
he's gonna run for office pray he's
gonna do something amazing right for a
guy his age but here's what I post them
I said so look I'm at the hotel I'm
walking Ron everybody here seems white
he says that's not true I said really
how many people you have here says I
have a thousand people here I said how
many are african-american hurt or
Hispanic he says we have a 20-6
african-american and 22 registered
Hispanics I see you're 95% white that's
the math right you are majority white he
says but what's your point I said this
is my point to you so what it seems like
is the following because look if if your
answer is true as to you having the same
political beliefs as your parents so is
Jerry so is Prager then what is the
solution to somebody who isn't to help
convert that person because to me when I
watch it okay I watch and I say okay CNN
MSNBC MSNBC is true they'll come out and
say listen we are left
not arguing it this is who we are
obviously a couple guys they have their
that's not Joe some of these other guys
maybe they're not fully left CNN tries
to play in the middle but you know
they're not there to the left
Fox yeah right everyone knows a stealing
one that's mainly right but if the job
is conversion not necessarily giving
birth to a bench Shapiro that grew up in
that family the job is conversion yeah
that's what we have to work on because
when I look at some data here's what I
notice in 1960 68 percent of
african-americans voted Democrat
okay 1960 68 percent 1964 it was 94
percent now we know why that is at that
time right now it's 88 percent of
african-americans they vote Democratic
on the Hispanic side Latino side it's
about 66 percent for Clinton it was
about 65 66 percent right you look at
this data if our job is to get up there
just kind of talk about what we believe
in crush all these debates and make off
points oh my gosh she killed it all this
but no one's converting right and it's
just entertainment yeah right so what
what do we do to help others and then
I'm not talking as an elite ahsoka
already about I'm just talking purely
how are how can you help other people
form their own opinions when they don't
have the luxury of being raised in a
family like maybe yours or maybe Jerry's
or cragars that they pretty much took
the values and principles that their
inner self I mean I think that the key
is that everybody is an independent
human being and you have to think as an
individual so that's why I say you know
no matter which house I grew up in I'm
sure they would have some impact on me
but I hope that as time went on I would
learn from life experiences and then I'd
start thinking as an individual not just
as my parents kid and not just as my my
wise husband but but and not just as you
know a Jewish guy but as somebody who
actually believes as an individual in
particular points of view and I said I
think you're starting to see that I
think the identity politics of the left
is starting to crumble a little bit
because it's become so restrictive you
know this belief that if you are a
member of a particular racial group that
you no longer are allowed to think
outside the box or if you're a member of
a particular sexual orientation you
can't think stuff that other people
don't want you to think a lot of folks
are starting to find this really
restrictive and galling and insulting
and they're starting to think okay well
maybe I'll take a look at some other
stuff for myself and when their folks
not just like me but obviously people
like Jordan Peterson or so
Harris or Dave Rubin and people who are
all over the map politically but who are
saying listen it's time for you to take
a look at the data on your own and
figure out for yourself what you think
that's an empowering thing I'm not
telling anybody what they ought to think
I mean I'm telling them what I think but
you you're a grown-up right you can make
up your own mind but that's the point
you are growing up and it's your job to
make up your own mind it's not your job
to follow what your parents told you or
what your racial group says you ought to
do you think a motivation to want to
step up and want to learn is higher or
lower today and why I think it's growing
I think that I do think I think that
anything that is whether you receive it
for a while and I think it's growing now
because again the political correctness
of the left is so restrictive and so
irritating and so nasty that people are
just reacting to it so you saw a story
this week about a white girl who put on
a chinese-style dress for her prom which
was getting beaten up on the internet
for put it for cultural appropriation I
think a lot of people on the left look
at that they go really like this is what
we're gonna be now we're gonna be that
if you're white you can never wear any
sort of dress from another culture or if
you're black you can't wear any sort of
thing from white culture like it's it's
so irritating and so maddening that
people are saying I don't want any part
of this anymore
like if I'm gonna be boxed into the
things I can and cannot do by this group
of cultural arbiters who tell me what's
appropriate and what's not when I'm
doing stuff that is completely
inoffensive and really not inappropriate
in any objective sense then screw that
I'll just I'll go out and I'll start
reading for myself I'll start thinking
for myself that's why I think you see
again that there is this growing crowd
of people who are following this set of
voices that has risen up in the last
three or four years really and my friend
Eric Weinstein comes with the
intellectual dark web and I think that
that's basically right again we all
disagree about politics we just agree
about basic questions about God but that
doesn't mean that we're not all reading
from the same hymnal when it comes to
you got a thing for yourself and you got
to make up your own mind based on the
data that is in front of you so you
think we're more divided today than
before in the past I think that one more
divided certainly now that we have in
any time in the last 35 years
go you go back to the 60s probably 60s
and 70s so let me ask you this since
we're on this topic here before we
transition into the next topic so if 88
percent of African Americans are voting
Democratic why do they vote Democratic
why is 88% we're not talking 60 percent
so
88 percent I think there are a couple of
reasons for that one
that the media have done an enormous ly
powerful PR job on Republicans
suggesting the Republicans are all white
not only are they all white they don't
care about you and that's why you know
the Democrats are widely perceived as
caring about black folks even though the
cities that they govern have actually
not done very well more a lot of black
folks living in those cities as Kanye
West is pointing out and he's right
about that you know I think the other
reason is that Republicans tend not to
talk a lot about morality and politics
they tend to talk about talk about
effectiveness in politics they'll talk
about an effective tax policy and if
you're sitting there going yeah my life
isn't fair then how does that appeal to
you so I think that that's another
factor and then finally I think that
there there are a lot of folks who are
growing up impoverished this is true in
every community but there's
disproportional poverty disproportion of
poverty in the black community so we're
speaking about the black community if
you grow up in poverty and you grow up
where everyone around you is they're not
a lot of fathers in the community
they're not a lot of people who are off
the government welfare system then when
someone comes to and they say listen
this is a meritocracy you don't have to
be on welfare you can let these see the
big house in Beverly Hills you can live
there you look at them like they're
crazy because no one you know has done
that right it sounds like a mythical
thing like why would you think that
literally everyone in your neighborhood
gets the you know maybe maybe out of a
job because of you know history or
because of circumstance or because of
growing up in an impoverished area
whatever the reason is and your and
someone's telling you well you can have
that three million dollar house one day
it's like well you sound like you're
selling me a bill of goods right this is
why I've said for a long time I think
what needs to happen is the private
industry needs to go into a lot of inner
cities and start actually creating
scholarship programs and some companies
are doing this and saying to black kids
for example listen you're 15 years old
yeah I know that you think that they're
not a lot of opportunities are going to
a crappy public school you feel like
they're you know they're not a lot of
dudes around in the community [ __ ]
modeling great behavior just as a
percentage so here's what we gonna do
you get good grades you get into a good
college and we will sponsor your college
with the scholarship program then after
done with college then you work for a
company for three years right and that's
and so now you're creating a system
where people are either dependent on
capitalism or they're dependent on
government better they should be
dependent on free-market capitalism then
they should be dependent on government
because again it's not anybody else's
fault if somebody puts a check in front
of you're gonna take it regardless of
your race there's not a racial thing if
some puts check in front of me
take the check so are you the question
is what kind of check is that gonna be
is that gonna come from private industry
or is that gonna come from a
redistribute of government program that
says it has your best interest at heart
who cares about you but what is that
what is the deeper deeper issue for a
cook I'm half Armenian half of Syria
yeah and if you know if you know about
Armenians Assyrians or Middle Easterners
they typically vote Democrats right okay
and so you'll sit there and there's this
same there you'll hear by the way it's
it's blacks Hispanics Armenia Middle
Easterners a lot of them right jusers
but that's right that's very strange
about the will change as well so in and
then it's you know Democrats care for
people Republicans care for their
pockets richer sayings and by the way
here's here's the thing it's so subtle
and so effective that it sticks somebody
says you know what I I just my mom told
me for years always we'll Democrat
because they care for the people
Republicans only care for the money
right so someone says that what's your
safe to that and which answer to that is
they obviously don't care for the people
because the impact their policies has
been dramatically terrible they're
they're raking it in are you raking in
it really how's your life is your life
dramatically improved because of the
Democrats in your area you keep electing
if the answer is no then maybe they
don't care that much so you notice that
what I'm not doing is saying no no we do
care because once you engage in that
conversation somebody says I don't care
about you you don't care about me and
you say no no I really do the
conversation is already over right if
you're in a relationship and your
girlfriend says to you you don't care
about me anymore you say no I really do
care the relationships done right
there's no way you're convincing her
that you care it's just not happy yeah
the only way that you can the only way
that you can combat this politically is
by saying you know the people who you
say are caring we're actually not caring
because the truth is that in politics
nobody really cares that much about you
right ok the Democrats don't care about
you the Republicans don't care about you
no one cares about you I'm honest enough
to say listen here's what I care about I
care about my immediate family I care
about my circle of friends and then the
rest of you I want to leave you alone
right and that's good it's good that I
want to leave you alone I don't care
enough about you to try and stop you I
don't care enough about you to try an
input to try and somehow infringe on
your rights I don't care enough about
you to think I can control your life my
job is to get people out of your way and
to get everybody else out of your way so
you can do what you can do and then it's
your job to succeed okay you're asking
anybody else to solve your problems I'm
not gonna solve your problems you're
gonna solve your own problems
Democrats are lying to you when they say
they're gonna solve your problems
they're not Republicans are lying to you
and they say they're gonna so I probably
want that though why do that why do they
like that why is
most people like that I mean most people
like the idea that somebody's gonna come
in and solve their problems for them and
if you haven't grown up in in in in a
community that suggests that it's your
job to solve your own problems and
suggest that you know where there have
been two generations of heavy levels of
dependence on government programs then
it's easy to equate that with caring I
don't blame people for that I mean
that's like you say that again you say
that to anybody you say I'm gonna take
away you know your Pell grants to a
bunch of colleges and they and they say
oh that's terrible how could you do that
my Pell Grant you don't care about me
well my answer is you're right I don't
care about you neither do the people who
are giving you the Pell grams people
giving you the Pell grants don't care
about you either they just want your
vote I care about you enough to say
listen you're on your own go major in
something that's gonna make you some
money right don't take $120,000 in loan
and go major and lesbian dance theory or
something they're gonna make it I'm
gonna make a lot of wonder right exactly
like why won't you go out and get a loan
from a private bank because they know
they're gonna have their money back and
that would actually be better for you
but that's your decision it's not my job
to sponsor your life you ever heard of
Fame you know economy that's better when
Democrats are president yeah that's that
so statistically speaking that's true
but it is also statistically speaking
true that when Republicans are in
Congress of late the economy's done
better I mean since 1994 you get the
entire Clinton boom so you can't really
it it doesn't match up quite that easily
it's otherwise you have to attribute the
the beginning of the economic downturn
of 2008 2009 you have to say that the
first year was Obama's fault also like
when does an economy become the
president's first of all I'm not of the
opinion that policy unless there's a
heavy policy change is really what
drives the economy I don't think that
tax cuts necessarily make the economy
boom or tax increases necessarily make
the economy spiral down I think there
are long term effects but they're a lot
more subtle than we pass the tax cuts of
the economy's booming or we pass a tax
increase the economy immediately tanks I
don't think that macro government policy
is usually large-scale enough remediate
enough to make that sort of change so so
logic emotion left promote you know
votes more emotionally would you say
right promotes more logically I would
say that I would take conservative
thought is more logical than leftist
thought but you know as far as
individuals voting I think most people
turn to vote emotionally right and left
so then based on what you're saying is
you know if a marketing agency wants to
hire a marketer you got a you got a hire
a Democrat instead of a Republican
because Democrats are better marketers
and Republicans are no question I mean
if it were just about policy then I
presume
most people would vote Republican
because I think Republican policies work
better but if it's about you know what
face you're presenting to the world
Republicans suck at this we're all goons
are awful Democrats are constantly
saying again it's we care we care they
don't care they're bad people there it's
always character attacks from the left
on the right it's no you see it's Paul
Ryan and he's explaining why we need to
restructure Social Security yeah good
luck with that Democrat lasted eight
minutes right exactly you got Joe Biden
out there saying that that Republicans
want to put y'all back in Chains and you
have Paul Ryan saying we want to
restructure your Social Security which
one of those messages do you think is
gonna be more effective so let me ask
you do you go to the point where if you
want to go against a great marketing
group you got a play to their same you
know a tactic well of course you have to
use a certain level of emotionality when
you're marketing on mass but my goal is
to what I do is to try and move people
logically enough that we can sort of
better ourselves in this way because I
think that I'd like to live in an
electorate where we actually have
reasonable decent arguments about the
stuff of that attacking each other
personally but if I'm running a campaign
when I would I use character attacks and
and personal attacks and emotion of
course because that's the way you win
right but that's not my job my jetha
that's why I would prefer to do my job
than do that job right in the job that
I'm in I prefer not to make character
attacks and instead have conversations
with people on the other side and we
either come to agreement or we know but
at least our positions have been
clarified it's tough to do when when
when everybody else is doing it you know
when when especially like even for
instance look at Romney Romney ran
terrible marketer oh yeah terrible
marketer right say good person never
drank 65 years all this stuff in you
know he comes out with my twenty nine
points to making the economy better and
people can't even handle one point that
129 points and he got a Trump comes out
and he says make America great again
simple and you have probably the most
qualified guy to become a president was
Jeb Bush he started day one with on or
forty million dollars
father brother grandpa me the whole nine
and there is no charisma at all right to
get any of it done and the marketer ends
up winning so so it so if that's the
case that's the case this kind of goes
and and I'm gonna come back still to the
part on on voting when you said
somebody's got to take the initiative to
want to learn for themselves if
marketing works and take us back to
social media today like where we are
right now with social media today so
Kanye West
comes out in Kanye West says what he
says right and he says hey I'm a free
thinker you know this is how I'm
thinking and then John Legend's sends
him a message says begin very I don't
know if you saw that part of text that
John Legend saying be very careful you
know teaming up with the Trump because
of this and then he says using my family
and my following and my fan base is a
and my legacy fear tactic and then
challenge and says since you're posting
my text online I just want you to know
which other was very to see that writer
you can see the side of John Legend that
maybe you didn't see because sometimes
it's complete opposite I can't talk to
you I can't believe any supporting him
so are we going in a direction and again
I asked this from some other people as
well are we going in the direction where
the person with the biggest following
who could controls the biggest follow
and say four years from now eight years
from now 12 years from now a 36 year old
guy's got a hundred and ninety three
million followers he's gonna come out
and become a president just because of
his following are we kind of going in
that direction where decision were there
okay so then so then let's transition to
this question if that's the case do we
have a problem with our current voting
system well I mean I think that we have
a problem with our mentality I'm not
sure it's a question of the voting
system meaning that which is which is
easier to adjust I mean you really think
that here's what I mean what's the
alternative well no here's what I'm
asking do you think you know this whole
thing about one parent when when people
get into their 30s and then you'll say
you know this next generation coming up
they're kind of lazy they're not hard
work yeah alright when I was their age
you know I would climbed you know to
school it was snow both and you know all
this stuff but you keep hearing it and
hearing it and every generation says
that about the prior generation as if
their generation was the hardest-working
generation so to me there's a part of it
where it's like oh my gosh people are so
lazy now this is a cyclical cycle that
would be gone for thousands of so if
that's the case and you're saying I
think it's a mentality do we really
think systematically percentage-wise
this mentality can be dramatically
changed or do we need to just say look
if we go this direction start your
political campaign at 16 years old let's
make sure in the next 20 years you've
got a hundred fifty million followers
and say some radical things go make some
videos go do that stuff so you can
become a president twenty you know
thirty-eight
tomah's gonna be that's why I go to the
voting system so are you are you
currently with the way our voting system
is are you comfortable with the way our
current voting system works more or less
amande it's it's the worst system except
for all the others so this is really
system except for the a as Churchill
said yeah I mean democracy is not a
completely flawless system for sure I
mean none of the founders thought that
it was no the Asians thought that it was
no doubt about it I mean you know and
there's a lot of people nowadays that
are coming out you know how there's this
whole new wave of I don't want to have
kids I don't want to buy a house I'm a
minimalist all this I'm not doing this
anymore right but there's also community
that's getting bigger that's saying I'm
not voting anymore because my vote
doesn't count your start to hear some
people say that my vote doesn't count do
you agree with that do you agree that
you know person's vote doesn't count
statistically speaking it doesn't but I
mean in terms of how you impact others
it obviously does so I think persuasion
like a dinner at the house of my wife
kids family if I'm having a conversation
about how to vote for that can possibly
go to
Nassim Nicholas Taleb he he has a new
book out called skin in the game and his
basic premise is that if you're not
showing you have skin in the game then
no one's gonna take you seriously so
when it comes to voting
that's the minimal skin in the game that
you can show somebody is I voted for
acts or I'm going to vote for acts that
you actually you know did the minimum
amount of driving to the polling place
and doing that that at least shows the
the people around you that you care a
little bit more about politics then
you're just jacking off over the dinner
table so I think that that's that's the
W about the truth about the dinner
yeah that would be unpleasant it would
go viral on YouTube though right you can
be President so let's let's transition
into a Kanye what do you think might
would not transition yes what do you
think Kanye is doing you think you think
what Kanye is doing is marketing or you
think what Kanye is doing is really what
Connie is going through currently today
so I'm not gonna try and retain his mind
because that would be absurd I'm not
sure anyone can read Kanye's mind got
tweets about fur pillows and antique
fish tanks like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna go there but I will say what I
think is good about it right what I
think is good about it is that he is
yeah as I said before breaking free of
this identity politics straightjacket
that's been put on everybody and he's
saying listen I may not know everything
right now and I don't know everything
right now but I'm out there to learn and
I want to hear differ a lot of different
perspectives I thought that the the rap
that he did with Ti and this is not my
stuff right I don't listen to rap in it
but I thought that wasn't quite the
hip-hop could exactly look at me I'm so
gangsta but it's is it with an A with an
ER I don't know
in any case the fact that he did that
rap with Ti where he's going back and
forth with him and then at the very end
he says okay we're gonna stop it here
and then we're gonna have a discussion
you know go out and discuss I think
that's really good stuff I think it's
really good sorry I think that I think
that the best thing that Kanye could do
right now is to continue to just hit
that point over and over and over not to
go out there and play pundit because I
don't think he's qualified to play
pundit but for him to say listen I know
what I don't know and what I don't know
is most things and you don't know most
things either and so for you to say that
it's your job to tell me how to vote
because of the color of my skin is
absurd right that I think would be great
like I think the what Konya should do if
our economy is business manager where I
have them do is sponsor a major
convention where it was just that it was
just a bunch of people from left and
right all getting together and having
panels and discussions and call it Kanye
Khan right and just have it and have it
be you know an open door policy where
anyone can speak about anything I think
that would be great for him and I think
that'd be good for the country actually
have you proposed that to Kanye I have
no I think we got to make a short clip
of this and posted straight change he's
very creative but he listens you know he
listens to Candice he's he's listening
to people that are responding
you know he's listening to people that
are proposing ideas that may you know
cannot tickle his mine into saying this
could actually lead to me learning more
I almost see him from what I seen I
don't know whether it's real or not but
what it seems to be very real is his
level of curiosity yeah that part to me
I think it's very sincere and I think
more than anything else we need more
people to be very curious so let me
wonder why is UC Berkeley so much in
love with Karl Marx Communist Manifesto
what is this editor guy named Adam Smith
welcome Nations what was that all about
so we need more people to be curious to
be wanting to see what's on the other
side so let's talk about Trump a little
bit I mean obviously when Trump was
going this is nothing new you you've had
to you had to talk about this before you
weren't a big supporter of Trump and you
were not going on saying you know go
vote Trump I think the biggest remedy
for Hillary yeah yeah so the biggest
names in the marketplace that were going
against them names was you and it was a
BEC right there was a lot of them but
Beck was going against there yeah who
said that they weren't gonna vote for
him I think that what I did say during
the election campaign over and over and
over is hear all the flaws of them hear
all the reasons I'm not voting for him
but if you do vote for him I totally
understand why you support
Hilary Clinton like I get I get the
arguments and I find them somewhat
convincing but I didn't find them wholly
convincing you know they if I if the
election were held today I probably vote
for him
whoops the election was held today so
for reelection and me I beat that so
that's a whole different story so so let
me ask you this panel started day one
who did you think was gonna win
Republican I'm talking 15 when when the
when when they first did you think I
thought the day the highest likelihood
is probably Rubio I back to Cruz in
primaries but I thought that Rubio is
most like Christie bullied him a little
bit at one session when they went back
you know sometimes it's really important
I think that was a very unfortunate when
Christie did that helped the Trump but I
thought it was kind of a there's a
political murder-suicide met Chris you
know young way took out Rubio and then
he was done that so he wasn't exactly
yeah Trump goes against Hillary now
obviously I've read so many different
things about this thing was it because
he was the best possible candidate was
it because Hillary was just the worst
possible candidate on the left so
there's some of both I would say the
heavier part lies on Hillary being the
worst possible candidate in the history
of mankind ever in all of eternity in
any possible university was the worst
candidate and the reason do you really
believe it up she was a garbage
candidate I mean not just a bad
candidate a flaming garbage dumpster
fire of a candidate I mean that's it
like she they and the proof of this is
that she lost Donald Trump like I don't
know how it's possible to lose a
presidential election to a guy with a
40% approval rating and his height right
so is it so it wasn't like Trump was
wildly popular and people were showing
up in mass numbers to vote for him he
wanted fewer votes in Wisconsin than
Mitt Romney did in 2012 he won the state
Romney lost the state why because Barack
Obama actually won people in Wisconsin
no one showed up to vote for Hillary
it was enormous you just sue yeah okay
you say that one more time since 2012
Romney won Romney won the same number of
votes as Donald Trump Romney went
slightly more actually than Donald Trump
in Wisconsin lost the state of Wisconsin
Trump won the state of Wisconsin no one
shows up to vote for Hillary Clinton
that's amazing right no it people
despised Hillary Clinton and I think for
good reason she was a terrible candidate
and I think she's a she's a horrific ly
corrupt human being but it's so that's
part of it right she ran a horrible
campaign she's incredibly unlikable like
they keep showing polls now as unpopular
as Trump is showing that if they ran a
reelection campaign now Trump would beat
her again right so it's not it's not a
fluke so there's that as far as from
being the best candidate I think in some
ways that one
in 2015 October 2015 I gave a speech at
University of Missouri and this you know
before any of the primaries have started
and I said I think that maybe the only
person who can beat Hillary Clinton
might be Trump for a couple of reasons
one because a lot of Republicans are in
this strat their strategy was if I can
peel off 10% of the Hispanic vote and
nothing can peel off 5% of the black
vote then maybe I can eat my way to a
victory
whereas Trump strategy was basically if
I eke out 2% more turnout from the white
vote than I went right his strategy
which is what he did in Michigan in
Pennsylvania in Wisconsin in Ohio he
basically said here's our base it
already but really heavily for Romney
now I'm just gonna get the turnout up in
that particular group and then I can
still win the election by winning a
little bit more of a group I already
have as opposed to trying to peel off a
large percentage of a group that I don't
have right the Rubio strategy would have
been go after Hispanic community try and
get that 65 percent down to 58% for
Democrats try to get the black vote from
88% Democrat to 84% Democrat and you win
right Trump's was like okay I know I'm
gonna lose this many Hispanics I know
I'm gonna lose this many black folks
instead I'm just gonna get my white
percentages up a little bit and I'm
going to get turnout up a little bit so
his strategy was largely geared toward
that and I think that that was a smart
strategy just demographically speaking
the other thing is that Trump had a
unique capacity to avoid the kill shot
and the reason for that is because Trump
is as I said many times a mud monster
right the guy is made of mud there's
just so much mud on him that if you
throw more mud at him it doesn't even
show up it's like black socks they never
get dirty right so the Trump was black
socks in this election it didn't matter
what you did to the black socks they
were still black whereas Hillary Clinton
every ounce of scandal that was put on
top of her it showed up yeah the media
are trying to portray her as cleaner as
clean as the driven snow and then every
time Trump would flex some dirt on her
it would really show up she would
collect her and be like whatever and
made it her what are you want right it
made no difference and that's why I was
so stunned that that his lawyer was
paying a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars to stormy Daniels because why
like if that had come out he probably
won more votes like it wouldn't have
hurt him in any way they Trump the other
things that Trump was willing to play
dirty right in a way that Romney was not
in 2012 and McCain was not in 2008 Trump
was willing to play dirty so Trump is a
hammer and as I said many times
throughout the election cycle
he's a hammer in search of a nail
sometimes he hits the nail and when he
does it's it's just political magic
sometimes he hits a baby right so you
just don't know whether he's gonna hit a
nail
babies when he hits a baby we oh my god
that's just terrible I kept that but
when he hits a nail you're like wow he's
the only guy in the world who would
actually take a hammer to that nail good
for him
but that gives him an edge he can get
away with anything
Ryan I mean he said the certain base
like itchy and said of himself he says I
can go out there right now you've heard
of the truest thing he said he could've
shot somebody on Fifth Avenue who'd had
the same number of motors no question no
question because Hillary was that
off-putting and also because Trump you
know who he is you know quantity so let
me ask you look when Barack Obama was
done after his term of eight years was
he at a point I mean it he would still
love people like them it was not like
his policies produce anything that was
out of the ordinary ously we went into
debt or trillions poor okay but still he
was liked he was loved it was he'd run
for a third term II would have won this
is not like my question would be to
follow it if Biden would have ran I
think that would one that's the point
okay I'm with you there but I think if
Biden runs in 2020 I think it was so you
think he's gonna win if we runs in 2020
- I think the odds would have to be in
his favor for a couple of reasons
Biden runs 2020 he beats Trump I think
that that I'd be surprised if not again
III go and put money on excite of money
in the last election right I put my
money where my mouth was and I lost a
crapload of money because I bet on the
CEO do that on the stance man don't give
odds how much you do how much of the
conspiracy do buy into the fact that
Clinton's had a meeting would Biden to
tell him not to run did you read up on
that at all yeah so what I do buy is
that they went to Barack Obama and they
said to Obama that we're going to use
some of the money that we gather to help
pay off your 2012 campaign and also that
you know I mean I'm obviously gonna win
the nomination
don't back bite and I think that I think
there was really more about Obama
backing buy and then it was about the
Clintons so yeah I believe that even
took place well there's no question that
Obama probably should have backed by
Denis in the primaries and probably
Hillary and Bill wind him and said
here's all the reasons why you shouldn't
back Biden that Obama refused to support
Biden in the primaries and that was it
provide how much different would have
things been if Biden ran he would want I
mean know if he is president today how
much I'm what would have been different
than what had been different I think
that you wouldn't have the tax cuts
which I think they're quite good I think
that you wouldn't have the the foreign
policy which is a lot better than the
Obama foreign policy I with regard to
Iran you wouldn't have ever guard to the
new alliance building in the Middle East
but in Saudi Arabia Israel Egypt Jordan
you wouldn't have the you wouldnt have
the movement of the embassy to Jerusalem
you wouldn't have harsh
measures in Ukraine against the Russians
you wouldn't have you wouldn't have a
domestic policy that was cutting
regulation this is this is why I say
that I didn't vote for Trump last time
but pretty good shot at vote from this
time because I had three worries about
president Trump going in and my worries
were one that he wasn't gonna govern
conservative because he had no record
and not only did he have no record he
was all over the place during the
campaign so he'd say things like Obama
cares the worst is just terrible and
then he would turn around he'd say
universal health care for everyone you
be like okay well which one of those is
it because he got a pack and then so I
was wearing his policy that worries been
largely alleviated at least in the first
year and a half because he's governed
the conservative like more conservative
than anyone I can remember he's given us
corset she's given us a bunch of a bunch
of appellate court justices like all of
this stuff is really good my second
worry is that he was gonna soul suck the
Republican Party meeting Republicans
we're gonna stop being conservative and
they were instead going to look at Trump
as a thought leader on issues like free
trade or like Russia or on his kind of
vulgar personal behavior I don't think
that's really happened so much I think
that people voted for him because they
wanted the policy and because they
didn't like Hillary Clinton and I think
that if somebody who were classier as a
human being or to run for president and
be popular enough they follow that
person too so I think that that that
worries been at least partially
alleviated and who knows it stands watch
I think some people make excuses for his
bad behavior I think know a lot of
people on the right to make excuses for
him which I don't agree with I can
praise his policy and still think that
he's kind of a heel when it comes to his
personal behavior and not kind of a heel
when it comes to his personal behavior
and then there is a you know number
three which is him poisoning the well
with a lot of young people and I was
really worried that he was going to
become as the face of the Republican
Party this toxic figure standing above
the entire conservative movement and any
time I try to convince somebody people
go Oh we'll look at Trump I mean he's
you're back in him and he's the worst
and I still worry about that but I think
the damage has largely been done already
so him being reelected would not
exacerbate the damage it would just be a
continuation of what's already happened
so most of the damage happened when he
was elected in that respect so a lot of
my worries about him being elected have
either been alleviated or they have or
they have been obviated by the fact that
he's already the president so so sounds
like you're going to be as a you know
you're gonna lead us political campaign
2020 the president wants somebody out
there on the campaign trail calling the
he'll personally but here's a question
for you is your president without Kelly
Conway yeah yeah no no no if if he
didn't bring Kelly on Conway on his team
was not that person who moved the ball
near abandon it really yeah I don't give
a lot of credit to Killian covers it
wasn't the messaging Trump didn't change
okay Trump was the same Trump in the
primaries I think she schooled a lot of
these CNN and MSNBC host when she would
sit down was watching and her persuade
me I think Kellyanne said is good at her
job but I don't think that you know I
don't think things radically interest in
Conway is not on the campaign I think
that the presidential race is between
the two candidates and Trump won so it's
more about Trump anybody else so you're
saying right now you're not obviously
not willing to put money on it but
you're saying right now 2020 bite and
runs he's probably gonna be winning yeah
you'd have to say that probably just by
the data I mean it's again he's got a
much higher approval rating Trump is
personally unpopular and also Trump he
emits this feeling of chaos all the time
you're probably just going to a basement
for two years and just let everything
calm down and cut out the Twitter and
just you know sign a bill every so often
go to his rallies of all people that he
likes then he would then I think he'd be
enrolled at shape but here's here's the
thing I've said this to top members of
the administration between 2000 and 2004
george w bush had to pick up 11 million
additional votes in order to win in 2000
he lost by 500,000 popular votes in 2004
he wins by about a million and a half he
has to pick up ten million votes between
2000 and 2004 do you know a person in
the United States who did not vote for
Trump last time who's gonna vote from
next time aside from me rather there's
there's not a ton of people who are out
there who have been convinced to vote
Trump now certainly not 10 million
certainly not 12 last time no no no no
no it's the Fluke East election American
history oh this is a popular vote by 2.5
million he's gonna have to pick up 12 to
13 million votes in the next election
cycle in order to win are there 12 to 13
million voters who are going to show up
to the polls and vote for Trump when
they either didn't vote last time or
argA or voted for Hillary Clinton I find
that very hard to believe because again
he is not somebody who's winning people
oh now it's a binary race right so that
means that I can say that in a vacuum
but it's possible if they run some illa
Kamala Harris or Kirsten Gillibrand
somebody really off-putting
then Trump could win but if they run
Biden Biden is a known quantity people
are relatively comfortable with a very
easy both sides by the way well there's
a lot more comfort I'm not coming
with him I think he's terrible but it
but but there is a sense of we've seen
this guy before so if he runs again it's
like okay back to stasis back to
normalcy I think he'd have a heavy
advantage in a run against but it's
going that by the way that he think it's
like 53:38 right now but the polls
showed Hillary was supposed to embarrass
Trump and Trump should have just left
and gone to China for six months true
well I'm just staying there
try not roots in the national polls
showed that she was gonna win by
anywhere from three to five points she
won by three so the national polls were
actually right it was the state polls
that were really skewed so when I say
the national polls showed no Biden
embarrassing Trump again that could
change worth three years out but the I
do place more credence in national polls
could have a broader sample size and
because the the sample is spread out
over a wider possible area you don't
have quite as much room for error as you
do in these state polls it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting what are the
chances of Elizabeth Warren I think that
she could win primaries but it depends
on who else runs in the primaries so
she's got the Hillary Clinton problem
which is that thirty percent of the base
of the Republican of the Democratic
Party in primaries is minority is black
and that means that if Kamala Harris
runs against Elizabeth Warren a lot of
Democrats vote for Kamala Harris and a
lot of black votes vote for the honors
and that that's a problem right it's the
2008 race all over again basically then
you've got Obama versus Hillary Clinton
with it was before and playing Hillary
Clinton and we know how that ended right
so how about how about this whole thing
about rock you know Oprah Winfrey the
whole story you're hearing about
remember we talk about worship and rocks
got a massive massive followership and
the guys probably I don't know how many
Republican or Democrat right this is
this is the real question if you ran as
a Democrat he has to embrace the
Democratic base isn't going to embrace
him unless he embraces certain
principles right they would have to
embrace he'd have to go like full
pro-choice which I don't know where he
is on that issue because there's not a
major Democratic politician it was not
he would have to engage in a certain
amount of intersectionality which I
don't know if he's willing to do I mean
in the past he's talked about running as
a Republican so I'm not sure whether he
actually would run as a Democrat but if
he ran as a Democrat he won the primary
he'd creme Trump I mean I don't think
that'd be a close election at all
actually because again he's much more
popular because he's must want to like a
bowl by far yeah by a monitor the rack
doesn't cream everybody if he runs
in the rocket and by the way he's a
pretty he's a pretty he's a pretty
astute dude he's a pretty astute dude
that was a word I was gonna use he's a
pretty astute dude he's not a
lightweight no I mean he's you know I
don't know that he's studied up on on
founding ideology but he knows how to
handle himself publicly for yes and the
other question is does you want that
life you know cuz his life's gonna
change really I mean his life is so much
better now that it would be if you have
why would he want that money it's it's a
pretty tough life I mean honestly and
also the campaign is really tough like
who really wants to wake up your kids at
home for a year and then just be out on
the road every day for a year that's
that's a really rough lifestyle that's
another thing that you didn't bring up
the one of the things I think Trump also
you know when you were watching Facebook
lives you saw Trump doing three four
five six days no question his work ethic
for a man at sixty nine years old
oh yeah is insane to think about a
person with us and everybody knew that
it was BS when his doctor wrote that and
that no no he the healthiest person who
ever lived where he's gonna live to 180
years old and all this but you watching
her on TV and you didn't have real
serious doubts about his health because
he was all over the place whereas
Hillary Clinton they were no wheeling
out of an ambulatory care every five
minutes and then she was collapsing into
bands and so the it did give a feeling
that he was a more vital personality
than Hillary no question yeah so anyways
I mean we're gonna have to wait and see
what's gonna happen between now and then
so a question for you going back to what
we were talking when he said mindset
right we have to we have to change the
way the mindset is thinking you know
people have to go out there and think
different way and challenge themselves
as a person who runs a business I've
6,500 agents around the country for the
United States what I notice and I try to
get my guys to be thinking about this as
well you will learn pretty much
everything about politics by running a
business here's why a person who
complains the most typically does the
least it is so weird our top performers
who do the most complain the least okay
and it doesn't matter what's going on a
complainer always finds a problem in
anything that we announce there's always
something that we did wrong or something
and on the complete opposite side you
know 11 quarters on our top-line revenue
keep speeding the progress you have
these guys that are getting better and
strong and all these other people are
coming up so to me I grew up a welfare
kid myself I grew up in Glenda I know
you're Burbank I'm a Glendale kid so I
want to Glenda
school in that community saw a lot of
welfare you saw a lot of section a you
saw a lot of those things going on and I
couldn't stand it I hate it
food stamps I hated lunch tickets I
didn't stand it at all so so today
running a company there are four things
that really infuriates me one is the
entitlement mentality I'm entitled to
XYZ victimhood mentality self-pity and
blame and from urine what are your
thoughts on that that's one two what can
be done about that for us to be able to
shift somebody's watching and saying you
know what I can't believe you're
thinking this I can't believe you say
this some people are true victims some
people are really going through this you
know why can't you just stop talking
about this kind of stuff you don't
understand what people you grew up in
this one so many people yeah what do you
say about that so what I always say to
folks is show me the evidence of where
you're being victimized by a particular
person so I can fight that alongside you
or get your nose to the grindstone right
you can't you can't just claim
generalized victimhood you can't just
claim generalized white privilege you
can't just claim that there's something
out there in the ether preventing you
from succeeding you have to show me
which policy is preventing you from
succeeding or the person who is standing
in your way who's preventing your
success and then I'm on your side
because I don't want to see that person
stop you from doing anything you want to
do either but if you don't have any of
that and it's just you saying that your
life situation sucks well buck up I mean
get over it like most people throughout
history have had life situations that
suck I'm lucky I've had a really nice
life I've had a really nice pretty easy
life but that's not true my grandparents
and probably not true your grandparents
it's not true of most people's
grandparents or great-grandparents and
so the bottom line is and even for
people who you know have lived a
relatively easy life it's not like
they've gone through a period they
haven't gone through periods that were
really rough I mean there's no question
that there's been stuff in my life I
don't like to talk about my personal
life very much but there's been stuff in
my life that certainly been very
difficult and that doesn't mean that you
know I can blame that on society nor
should anybody else I mean bottom line
is as I say if I had a slogan you know
aside from the facts don't care about
your feelings if you solve your own
problems because most problems are I
can't solve your problems for you and
either can society you can solve most of
the problems that are in front of you
and you certainly can't complain about
society victimizing you when you're not
making the most basic decisions in order
to prevent yourself from being
victimized
right if you're somebody who got
pregnant at 17 and had a baby out of
wedlock that was a bad decision right
you made a bad decision there and that's
a consequence you're gonna have to bear
now the question is gonna make a series
of good decisions to help get yourself
out of that hole and make sure the
introduce you all the time right
or are you gonna sit there and complain
that America's an unfair place because
as a single mother you have to face so
many more obstacles of course you have
to face so many more obstacles there's a
decision that was made that has some
obvious ramifications in the real world
and that's not to say they are a bad
person it is to say that a bad decision
is a bad decision regardless of who's
making it as I'm with race it has
nothing to the class right anybody who
makes a bad decision is going to pay for
that bad decision in one way or another
so make good decisions and then you're
gonna have less to complain about as a
general matter so here's a question for
you I don't I'm not gonna draw it out
I'll just kind of say it and see
visually maybe we can paint it so do you
think a system gives birth to a
mentality meaning a system gives birth
to victim enter mentality entitlement
self pity blame or do you think it's
ingrained from the individual again let
me go a little deeper in this I'm gonna
go a little deeper into so this makes
sense q do you remember when
unemployment checks are at 24 months
like I was four years ago five years ago
and people get it you could get on
employment check oh this guy you don't
understand he can't find a job though
economy sucks the market sucks and if we
have to extend it from 12 months for to
18 months to 24 months and then the
moment the unemployment checks stop they
started applying for jobs that all this
other stuff was taking place right how
did you get your jobs six-mile well I
don't have a check coming in right so do
you think a system gives birth to victim
had mentality or is it the individual
that thinks that way I mean I generally
think that it's it's systems and
cultures that ingrained victimhood
mentality so I think that there are
obviously government incentives to
believe that your victim in some areas
like welfare for example I think that
there are cultural elements to to
victimhood mentality and again this is
cross racial if you read hillbilly ology
by JT Vance he talks about you know
white communities in in kind of the
Appalachia area where there's this
victimhood mentality and grain but I've
been screwed something happened to me
and it's been handed down generation to
generation that you've been screwed by
the society at large and it comes from
your parents yeah and then there are
some people who are just you know
predisposed to being complaining you
know there's some biological evidence
and it's not racial in nature at all but
every individual I mean you know this in
your own life friend you know people who
you know who've been you know kind of
unhappy since birth and people who are
just born happier there is some truth to
that
absolutely so there's a look at each
individual to determine what was the
impact on the victimhood mentality of
each of these particular factors but as
an overall statement as
society that keeps promoting a
victimhood mentality and and giving you
credit and kudos more you claim your
victim the more we sympathize with you
and the more we feel bad for you the
more stuff we give you that's certainly
not going to inculcate a sense of
responsibility or self-worth fair enough
so so so what about the fact that you
know sometimes you hear I'm Armenian we
just had the Armenian Genocide April
15th I don't know if you follow you know
Armenian Genocide is Syrian Genocide
Greek Genocide the whole thing with the
Young Turks back in the days and no the
Ottoman Empire took down a total of 1.5
million Armenians
I think it's 750,000 Greeks and 350
thousand Assyrians it's a number in that
range and so the Armenians you know they
go on a March and they talk proudly
about wanting to just make this a day
that had happened America to accept that
this happen a lot of different countries
actually his Germany Brazil France many
different countries have said this event
took place right America hasn't done it
allies would with turkey that hasn't yet
taken place first murder sure it is real
shred yeah the countries that have not
yet
America should Israel should why do you
think they haven't yet is it
specifically the foreign policy decision
I assume that it's just they they feel
that they're allied with the Turkish
government and air21 who is in fact an
Islamist is is spending in you know he's
basically threatened that he's going to
cut off military communications with
particular countries if they if they
were to support the idea that there was
no Armenian Genocide although obviously
there was no president has yet you know
said it and obviously Barack Obama said
it as a senator I think an O for Genesis
I think it's a foreign policy issue more
than it is yeah the more I every every
place I read about goes back to the
relationship with Turkey and they have
to keep it strong and all this other
stuff but anyways the point I was going
with this was the final you'll hear
sometimes people say we don't understand
that my generation went through slight
the slavery my family went through
slavery you know my family went through
this my family went through that
although it is true what I see sometimes
is and I'm curious to hear your thoughts
is clinging on that as the reason why
I'm not winning today I'm not winning
right day because my family went through
this my generation went through this and
you don't know what it is to have a
blood that went through this what are
your thoughts on that my feeling is that
pretty much every group in history has
been victimized at one time or another
and some of the more recent than others
right
in the Jewish community went through the
Holocaust significantly later than the
black community went through slavery but
that's the question is not where your
grandparents victimized or where your
parents victimized or even were you
victimized the question is what are you
going to do now all right forget about
history forget about like what happened
yesterday what are you going to now to
fix your life and if you don't have a
plan to fix your life right now if your
plan to fix your life right now is to
say yesterday I got mugged that's not a
plan right and if you're and if your
plan is to say my grandparents got
mugged that's certainly not a plan right
so so there's no question that there's
been historical injustice the question
is what are the obstacles to your
success right now if there are legal
obstacles to your success then we can
work together to remove those because I
think every good hearted person wants to
see if there is racist legislation on
the books that wants the unbraced its
legislation go away and we can all fight
for that that's great but what decisions
are you making in your own life do you
have a plan you have a plan or is your
plan basically to say that until society
changes you can't change your own
behavior I mean that's that's a real
Marxist trope right I mean the Marxist
ideology suggests that in society that
defines the individual not the other way
around that you can't better yourself
because society restricts you in every
way even the language we use is
patriarchal and capitalistic and all
this kind of stuff and so we have to
transform the entire society by leveling
it and then we'll have a brand new
humanity that's not real okay human
nature is human nature it's always been
human nature and always will be human
nature and that means you're gonna have
to work within the confines of human
nature but the way to better yourself is
to recognize those confines and then to
work on the things that are wrong with
you now I don't know a single person
who's worked on bettering themselves who
hasn't actually had a better life than
they started with I know a lot of people
who have worked on veteran society who
have exactly the same or a worse life
and they have anything whatever they
were trying to that why do you think you
think it's a nature thing because it
just focuses on trying to change other
people instead of myself yeah it's
easier I think also because it makes you
feel like you're making a difference in
the world right it gives you a sense of
purpose it gives you a sense of I'm
changing the world right when you're 17
18 you want to change the world you
don't want to say okay how do I change
myself you know how do I make myself a
better person that's it's a pretty
religious worldview honestly the the
self-betterment
general view and it's pretty secular
worldview the the whole gotta change the
world around me and we're gonna fix the
world and the world has to be fixed it's
his time as Seoul says the quest for
cosmic justice it's a lot more romantic
the quest for cosmic justice then the
quest to you know work two hours longer
at the Macdonald so you can take that
money and then and then create a college
fund like that's it's not quite as
romantic have you
ever done anything together no time so
very sorry this is one book was a reason
was it reason or a reader I don't know
what it was here's a book where was some
of it to Marcus Aurelius meditations
where he talks about all these different
areas of life and I thought it was
incredible so fantastic I mean have
asked me for years if I could select any
person in United States to be president
who would it be and I always a soul soul
soul I am a die-hard Milton Friedman fan
and it was great seeing these two guys
when they were going at it back in the
days with the real debates the Buckley's
do ya medalie mean you could see some of
that stuff so to finish up with your
thoughts you wrote two book I mean
you've written a lot oh yeah I think
you've written seven books in your last
one was a New York Times bestseller
bullies right yeah oh yeah yeah so so so
let's talk about the the brainwashed one
about the educational system and then
let's talk about the bully's want and
then let's wrap it up from there so
brainwash you wrote this book I think
the title uh title utilizing doctrine
America's high universities in doctrine
American youth so talk about that a
little bit so the college system
unfortunately is not built for actual
inculcation of skills except in certain
particular areas so if you're in the
stem areas then maybe they're teaching
you a skill set that you can use like my
wife was an neuro psychology major
neurobiology major and she's a doctor so
that was obviously teaching her to
become the predicate for a doctor I was
a Poli Sci major I'd learned anything
right it was a complete waste of time
the only thing as good for was
credentialing so then I could go to
Harvard Law School the same thing is
true in a lot of liberal arts and those
liberal arts which originally were
designed to sort of broaden your
worldview and make you think in a new
way it's not really about that anymore a
lot of professors are using these sort
of little indoctrination centers for
their own particular political point of
view and that's what that book was about
it was about the fact that so much of
higher education is a stacked with this
with even in the syllabus with a
particular political worldview that is
that is of the left I mean there's
almost universal condemnation of the
right on college campuses I think part
of that is again you have a bunch of
very smart people who are sitting around
talking with each other and they think
okay if we rule the world the world
would be a better place and part of that
is also that there's a self-perpetuating
system in academia where in order for me
to get a PhD I have to find a professor
at the University to sponsor my
dissertation well if that person is on
the Left they're not gonna be sponsoring
the right wing dissertation so you're
almost appointing your own successors
once you have a bunch of left wing
professors who are at the top of the
ph.d
them the next round of professors are
almost universally going to be members
of the political left let me ask you our
professors out of touch of reality I
mean a lot of them are I mean a lot of
them aren't working in the in the real
world a lot of them are they're getting
$150,000 or $200,000 salary for talking
about ideas that have been obsolete for
100 years so that's that's not you know
it's not a great way to stay in touch
with with current would you would you
put them and a billionaires kid in the
same world as in you know when you have
you've been so out of touch with what
really takes place at the in the world
but you speak and everybody's like oh my
gosh but this person is a professor but
this one's a bit you think there's a
little bit of that elite nurse going on
there's no question there's an elite
mentality and when I when I first
started at Harvard Law that we had a big
event and Elena Kagan is now in the
Supreme Court was the Dean of Harvard
Law and we had this big event as 500
students are open in class and we were
in this beautiful room I'm trying
remember which Hall it was but it was
this gorgeous room and it's and we're
all sitting there and she turns to all
of us and she says listen you're here
now the competition is over because I
don't worry about competition with each
other the competition is over you're
here you guys are gonna be ruling the
universe you're gonna be you're gonna be
running the Supreme Court gonna be
running Congress you're gonna be running
the presidency if the people in this
room are gonna be running the world and
I just thought to myself why Wow like
why like as we scored well on the LSAT
like so that but that mentality is
pretty prevalent at a lot of top
universities professors it's interesting
I was at Harvard Business School during
the first or a Clinton Trump debate and
I was there for their OPM program I
don't know if you're the owner president
management press like a three week
program you stay in campus so I'm asking
all the professor's hey so which way you
lean politically and you just listen to
everybody how much they were bash and
Trump the entire time right so then the
night comes where everybody's gonna go
out and watch the debate and we're in
this one hall I don't know it was a the
chow hall really high in cha Hall by
some gentleman named Chow I actually was
actually chow so we're sending 200
people there then if there was five
people that were rooting for Trump yeah
that would be a big number oh yeah I
could not believe Alex universe how many
people were all Hillary and I think some
of that is because of the policy and
some of it is there is a cultural
disdain for Trump because Trump is
obviously you know I won't say the Trump
I think Trump's a real Hayek you got I
don't think he's a real high IQ guy and
there's a real intellectual think or you
don't think I do not think I think that
I think is a real intellectual elitism
at a lot of these or even went to
Wharton you don't put him as a high IQ
guy no I mean have you seen a tweet I
mean no I think he went to Wharton
because his daddy was Richard yeah the
higher IQ guy Wow no I mean I've said
this over and over I really don't think
that he said you know so he's a dummy
but I don't think that he's I don't
think he's like oh would you consider
140 Aikido no no no no no no I'm not
saying that but would you consider him
like a if you have to have one of them
being a wartime general based on
strategies who would you choose him or
Obama strategy strategic well I think I
think Obama's better strategist in the
mid room I think a better political
strategist than Trump - I think I think
Trump's a better puncher but I think I
think Obama's a better strategist it
depends you need a general who's gonna
run you know you need a general for a
full frontal attack to run somebody over
a peck Trump you need somebody who's
gonna you know figure out a couple of
clever flanking maneuvers you probably
pick Obama but I wouldn't want Obama as
commander-in-chief let alone a general
so yeah you know they doesn't quite fit
I don't want another water bomb anywhere
near our military so so let's talk about
you the other book you're you're one you
read some books brainwash bullies I'm
sorry bullies yeah I want you want you
talk about that a little bit I mean the
basic thesis of bullies is that the left
has decided that they no longer want to
take part in serious argumentation that
prefer to slander your character so if
you are a if you're a pro-gun person
it's not that you're a pro gun because
you have certain principles and those
principles differ from
anti-gun people it's that you hate
children you don't care if they're dead
children if you are a person who doesn't
believe that the welfare state is a good
thing and you're thinking that it
promotes a victimhood mentality and you
think that it makes people dependent on
government it's not because you care
about people it's cuz you hate poor
people and this has been the left
consistent line of attack for years and
years and years and years it's only
exacerbated in recent years it's gotten
a lot worse I think and rizieres I think
that's why you're seeing a backlash now
because now if you if you so much as
breathed the wrong way the left
declares you a bad person and
untouchable and and applau and once you
throw enough people out of the out of
the window by calling them deplorable
you find that there are more people
outside the window then inside the
inside the tent and then you've got a
problem on your hands I think that's
what's happening to the left right now
if the Claire so many people are out of
the realm of reasonable discussion and
it's like five of them who are left in
the realm of reasonable discussion you
have to be somewhere in the in the
Bernice and Barney Sanders Tana he
Coates for Hillary Clinton triangle if
you're in that triangle then you're fine
that triangle then we can't even talk
with you you're a bad person that's
amazing to me that's amazing to me I
actually think from watching it from the
outside I think the level of
accountability is higher today with the
media than before there's a bit of a
threat there's a bit of a let me be
careful what I mean you just watch a
lemon is a little bit more uncomfortable
you watch the guys on MSNBC there are a
little bit more comfortable
uncomfortable than they were before it's
like we can no longer just say a
propaganda type of a thing and it's
gonna be fine someone's gonna come and
call us out tomorrow Bobby we talked
about Trump and Twitter I think Jack
Dorsey he needs to send a love letter to
Trump because Trump brought so much
value to Twitter stop at a point when
Twitter was no one really knew where
Twitter was going to weather became what
it is after Trump because that's where I
gonna I wasn't there before but now it's
a new center there you go to a website
every morning I wake up and see what the
news cycle is by checking Trump's
Twitter feed you guys it's the most
exciting one so been three books that
changed your your way of thinking three
books that had the most influence on you
what would you think well not much some
one lesson my Henry Hazlitt which got
really good kind of slim primer on on
economics quest for cosmic justice by
solo and the Federalist Papers so those
would be the three off the top I mean
aside from the Bible obviously cuz I
grew up with that but the bet three that
I picked on my own would be it would be
those three very cool okay so bend your
handle on Twitter's at apt Ben Shapiro
just Ben Shapiro the way it is so while
you're watching this whether you agree
or disagree and if you like that idea he
brought up with Kanye West by the way I
kind of thought that was a pretty fun
connieyc on and and and Ben is one of
the ones that goes there send Ben a
tweet at Ben Shapiro and let him know
what your biggest takeaway was from
today's interview and if you like the
idea with Kanye West's also put the
handle at Connie or whatever Connie has
handle is we'll put it up here on the
screen as well put both of them together
push Konya to watch this interview maybe
he's gonna reach out to Penn to do
something with them again brother thanks
I really enjoyed it thank you
you